you've written about
and made the case that we should take
ufo sightings
more seriously so that's one of the
things that uh
i've been uh inundated with
sort of the excitement and the passion
that people have for the possibility of
extraterrestrial life
of life out there in the universe i've
always felt this excitement
i'm just looking up at the stars and
wondering what the hell's out there
uh but there's people that have more
like uh
more uh grounded excitement and passion
of actually interacting with the
with aliens on this here our planet
what's the case they from your
perspective for
taking these sightings more seriously
the data from the navy to me seemed
quite serious
i don't pretend that i have the
technical abilities to judge it
as data but there are numerous senators
at the very highest of levels former
heads of cia
brennan i talked to him did an interview
with him i asked him what's up with
these
what do you think it is he basically
said that was the single most likely
explanation
as of alien origin now you don't have to
agree with him
but look if you know how government
works these senators or hillary clinton
for that matter or brennan
they sat down they were briefed by their
smartest people and they said
hey what's going on here and everyone
around the table i believe
is telling them we don't know and that
is sociological data
i take very seriously i have not seen a
debunking
of the technical data yes which is
eyewitness reports and images and radar
again at a technical level
i i feel quite uncertain on that turf
but evaluating some of the testimony of
witnesses
it seems to me it's now at a threshold
where one ought to take it seriously
yeah there's a one of the problems with
ufo sightings
is that because of people with good
equipment
don't take it seriously it's such a
taboo topic
that you have just like really shitty
equipment collecting data
and so you have the blurry bigfoot kind
of situation where you have just bad
video and all those kinds of things
as opposed to uh i mean there's a bunch
of
uh people uh avi lowe from harvard
uh talking about amu amua it's it's just
like
people with the equipment
to do the data collection don't want to
help out
and that creates a kind of divide
where the scientists ignore that this is
happening and there's the masses of
people who are curious about it
and then there's the government that's
full of secrets that's
leaking some confusion
and it creates distrust in the
government it creates distrust in
science
and it prevents the scientists from
being able to explore some cool
topics some exciting possibilities that
they should be be curious kids like avi
talks about
even if it has nothing to do with aliens
yeah
whatever the answer is it has to be
something fascinating we already know
everything's interesting but this is
fascinating
uh but look that all said i suspect
they're not of alien origin and let's
let me tell you my reason the people
who are all gung-ho they do a kind of
reasoning in reverse or argument from
elimination
they figure out a bunch of things that
can't be like is it a russian advanced
vehicle
no probably pretty good arguments there
is it a chinese advanced vehicle
no is it people like from the earth's
future
coming back in time no and they go
through a few others they have some
really good no arguments then they're
like well what we've got left is aliens
yeah this argument from elimination i
don't
actually find that persuasive you can
talk yourself into a lot of mistaken
ideas that way
yeah the positive evidence that it's
aliens
is still quite weak the positive
evidence that it's a puzzle
is quite huge and then and whatever the
solution to the puzzle is
it might be fascinating it's going to be
so weird or fascinating or maybe even
trivial but that's weird in its own way
that we can't set up by elimination all
the things that might be able to be
yeah and just like you said the
debunking that i've seen
of these kinds of things are
less explorations and solutions to the
puzzle
and more a kind of half-hearted
dismissal
and avi as you mentioned to him on your
podcast with him
he's been attacked an awful lot and when
i hear the idea carrier attacked
i get very suspicious of the critics
uh if if he's wrong like just tell me
why yeah like my ears are open
i don't have a set view on omuamua you
know
i know i can't judge avi's arguments he
can't convince me in that sense i'm too
stupid
to understand how good his argument may
or may not be
and not like you said ultimately in the
argument is uh in the in the meeting
of that debate is when we've where we
find the wisdom
like dismissing it that's one thing that
troubles me there's a bunch of people
like nietzsche sometimes dismissed this
way ayn rand is sometimes dismissed this
way
oh here we go like the there's a as
opposed to arguing against her ideas
dismissing it all right and that that
that's not productive at all uh she may
be wrong in a lot of things but
like laying out some arguments even if
they're basic human arguments
that's that's where we arrive at the
wisdom i love that
you